mysterious andorians a reference to
unrequited love a return to a familiar
star system here are all of the easter
eggs you missed in star trek strange new
worlds episode 2.
the series's second episode children of
the comet begins with a log entry from
cadet uhura she's still getting used to
life aboard the enterprise and is about
to attend a dinner in the captain's
quarters there she meets the ship's new
chief engineer an andorian named hemmer
but hammer is no ordinary andorian the
normally blue-skinned antennaed aliens
who debuted in the original series
episode journey to babel hemmer is a
subspecies of andorian known as enar who
live in frozen wastelands on andoria as
seen in the enterprise fourth season
episode appropriately titled the inar
when ahura spots hammered chopping
vegetables she offers to assist knowing
he's visually impaired as inar are all
blind spock points out that hammer's
other senses compensate for his
blindness to which the inar responds
compensate
they are superior
it's also mentioned that the inar have a
form of precognition and spock helps
demonstrate hammer's telepathic
abilities both of these unique abilities
were showcased in the enterprise
three-part story that introduced a young
inar woman named jamel and her brother
gareb who until now were the only inar
ever seen on star trek in that story the
romulans kidnapped gareb and used his
abilities to pilot a deadly new drone
ship in an attempt to provoke a war
between galactic powers
during his dinner with the crew captain
pike entertains with the story from his
earlier years he was chasing down a
pantsless nausican while working a
security job and fell flat on his face
after tripping over the alien's pants
fazer still in hand it's an incident
that would apparently play at least some
role in his switch to command but it
wasn't the last time a future enterprise
captain would tangle with some nasty
nausicans while we haven't seen noskins
that often this brutish alien race made
a memorable first impression in the next
generation episode tapestry in that
story picard dies and meets q in the
afterlife he offers him a chance to go
back in time and change his past in
doing so picard revisits a violent
incident from his early days in
starfleet while awaiting his first
orders after graduating from starfleet
academy picard and two friends have a
run-in with some nausicans who attempt
to cheat them in a game of domjot
defending his friend from a vicious
melee picard is impaled through the back
by one of the aliens requiring him to
have an artificial heart implanted that
he'd carry for the rest of his natural
life thankfully it doesn't sound like
pike's brush with nausicans was quite so
harry
the second episode of strange new worlds
takes the enterprise to the persephone
star system a planet that is endangered
by a massive comet that is due to strike
its surface in a world ending event in
his briefing spock says that the people
on the planet are primitive race with no
way to know the threat they face and no
way to stop it with the people below
unable to save themselves pike and the
crew get to work on finding a way to
divert the comet from persephone e3 but
this won't be the last time an
enterprise crew makes a visit to
persephone it originally popped up in
the first season of star trek the next
generation set nearly a century later
though it wasn't persephone 3 the
enterprise d visited the persephone
system briefly in the episode too short
a season in that story picard and his
enterprise crew traveled to persephone 5
to pick up a renowned federation
negotiator the elderly admiral mark
jameson from there they wrapped a morton
fork to oversee the release of prisoners
taken in a terrorist hostage situation
things don't go as planned of course
it's revealed that jameson himself may
be responsible for the crisis the
fallout from another incident he was
involved in decades before
nurse christine chapel and mr spock had
a brief interaction in the premiere
episode and their encounter in children
of the comet made it clear there's some
serious tension there at least from
chapel's side of things as spock la'ann
uhura and lieutenant sam kirk prepared
to beam to the surface of the comet
chapel inoculates them with an
anti-radiation drug when she administers
a dose to spock she openly flirts with
the vulcan science officer though spock
doesn't seem to notice uhura does
however and mocks him later in the
episode sarcastically referring to
chapel as his girlfriend i am a vulcan
we are too honest by nature
your girlfriend must love that huh the
sparks are of course a direct reference
to the original series in which nurse
chapel played by series creator gene
roddenberry's wife mitchell barrett
showed an open attraction to spock and
even got jealous of his relationship
with dupring it was in the episode the
naked time that chapel professed her
love for him and in plato's stepchildren
they even shared a kiss though in the
episode it was while they were coerced
by alien telepaths and neither was
entirely comfortable with the encounter
under the influence of a love potion
spock himself became infatuated with
chapel in the quasi-canonical star trek
the animated series episode mud's
passion where strange new worlds will
take their relationship remains to be
seen
inside the alien structure on the comet
surface the landing party discovers a
mysterious alien egg unable to get many
readings it's up to uhura to decipher
the inscription on the egg's surface and
find a way to lower the comet's
artificial shielding if she can't the
comet will destroy persephone iii aurora
unwittingly discovers how to communicate
with the egg when she begins humming an
old kenyan folk melody to alleviate her
anxiety as it turns out the comet's
intelligence communicates through
musical tones die hard trekkies will
recall that in the original series ahura
had shown an aptitude for singing and
was seen doing so on more than one
occasion she was most fond of a song
called beyond antares which she sang in
two different episodes the conscience of
the king and the changeling later in
children of the comet ahura and spock
sing together to communicate with the
intelligence and as star trek fans know
this wouldn't be the last time they
performed side by side in the 1966
episode charlie x spock plays a vulcan
loot while ahura accompanies him with
her sweet voice performing a song titled
oh on the starship enterprise
as the landing party works inside the
comic to alter its course pike and the
enterprise find themselves confronted by
an alien ship the beings on board it
refer to themselves as the shepherds
they warn pike not to interfere with the
comet which they believe is a kind of
divine lifebringer this is a powerful
starship that the enterprise can't
compete with so they're careful not to
anger them but they can't abandon the
mission to save the planet either when
they're finally forced into a firefight
pike issues a command to get them out of
there barking escape pattern april
omega-3
this is a clear reference to robert
april the former enterprise captain who
we met in the strange new world's
premiere april became official canon in
an episode of star trek discovery where
his name appeared on a computer screen
as part of a list of starfleet's most
decorated captains alongside pike
jonathan archer matthew decker from the
original series episode the doomsday
machine and philippa giorgio given that
april has an escape maneuver named after
him it's no wonder he's considered one
of the best
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
star trek strange new worlds are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]
you